should be sitting in reiches right now
on
bail should be indicted this week and
taken off our
streets you want to know why our cops
are getting
assaulted there's no consequences and we
must change this he's exactly right this
morning outrage here in New York City as
a fifth migrant walks free after bail
after as you see right there brutally
beating New York City police officers
two of them in the heart of Time Square
here's video of the fifth migrant
walking out of the courtroom before
flipping off the
cameras turn it's right now to find out
if it would ever happen in her state is
the governor of the great state of South
Dakota governor Christine noome Governor
good morning to you good morning thank
you Steve for having me on and you know
how it is in these big uh Northeastern
Sanctuary cities like where I'm sitting
this guy beat you know Alle ually beats
up a cop hasn't been adjudicated uh
walks free next thing you know he sees a
camera he flips him off that's what
we're dealing with in some
cases it is we have dangerous criminals
coming across our border and they're
impacting our cities and now we have
them beating up cops all of these
individuals need to be deported
immediately uh we need to start
enforcing our laws and we need the
federal government to stop tying our
hands that's one of the things that I to
I talked to our legislature about
yesterday I did a joint address which is
pretty precedented talking about the
invasion at our Southern border and how
it's impacting South Dakota I don't
think a lot of our population Even in
our legislature and throughout our state
know that we have the presence of
Mexican cartels here in our state it is
impacting our communities people are
suffering from the drugs and the
trafficking and we have to take action
but we need a leader in the white house
and we expect Joe Biden to do his job
yeah well good luck on that because
Governor we heard Joe Biden a couple of
days ago when he's going to an event he
said look uh uh I've done everything I
can it's up to Congress watch this real
quick here's some Senators
reacting agrees across the political
spectrum that Congress has a
responsibility to step up and give the
president whoever it is tools and when
you have somebody like Lanford getting
together with people on the left and say
here are tools we can all agree on we
should get that I would like to see the
Republicans give the administration the
money they say they need in order to get
the border security that the Republicans
claim they want so right now where's the
money Republicans they're holding it up
all you have to do is take a look at the
numbers you're having millions of people
come through hundreds of thousands God
ways give me a briak okay ultimately if
anything's going to happen in Congress
th those same people who are blaming
Republicans are going to have to do
something about it
Governor we need the president to do
something about it listen US senators
have been talking about fixing
immigration for decades uh and we see
completely different consequences from
who's in the White House under under
President Trump we built a wall we had a
remain in Mexico policy there were
dozens of policies that made a
difference and gave us a secure border
it's very different under Joe Biden
we're seeing unprecedented illegal
immigration it's coming into this
country as an invasion it is a war zone
down there I was the first governor to
deploy National Guard to our Southern
border three years ago and we're
continuing to work to to support that
effort but listen Steve I have one of my
Native American tribes that is suing the
federal government over not protecting
their people over not uph holding the
law and giving them Tribal Law
Enforcement Officers when they need it
to keep their communities safe I'm
supporting them in that but it's
affecting some of our poorest and our
most isolated communities and it's
because the cartels are here they're not
just at the border they're here in South
Dakota and they're bringing fentanyl in
that's killing our kids and trafficking
our children so real briefly as as
you've depicted you've got the cartels
from Mexico on the reservations in South
Dakota governor if if uh some people
from uh in the country illegally some of
these migrants uh beat up a cop on the
streets of South Dakota would you Deport
them immediately cuz here in New York
it's not a problem yes there will be
consequences absolutely we would do that
in a heartbeat I I think that's the
problem is that we see no consequences
and they're allowed to come into this
country they don't want to be uh free
and embrace our liberties like Americans
do they're coming here for a different
purpose and we see different countries
like Venezuela emptying out their
prisons and their me mental institutions
not wanting to have these individuals be
their responsibility anymore those are
the individuals they're sending here to
our country that we're taking in and
we're going to have problems like this
in our cities but across the country if
we continue to allow it to go on I think
you're exactly right uh Governor thank
you very much for joining us today from
PI thank you Steve have a wonderful day
you as well I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis